before lunch Valentine cabin EPS Oh
doesn't show was a very pretty picture
so sorry for the technical delay so I
can talk about measure properties MCS
fees and connections to circuit lower
bounds so some of the stuff that Rahul
mentioned in he is nice survey overview
and I'll touch upon similar themes but
I'll give you my take on it and also
gives to tell you something about
different results so it's basically
based on a couple of joint works with
marco rosso Antonina and ilya Vuckovich
so basically we're going to explore some
connections between mcsp that will be
the sender character in our story with
circular bounce learning pseudo
randomness and a bit of proof complexity
so let me define our remind you what
mcsp is you've seen it several times
already so here's the definition they
give a truth table of some function
given explicitly upsize to the little
end and some parameter s and you want to
know if there's a small boolean circuit
computing your and again the trivial
observation is that this problem is
obviously an NP there's a certificate
name with the circuit itself but we
don't know why if it's np-complete even
though probably is I'll talk a bit about
this
so what's the connection from mcsp
to circuit lower bounds I viewed this as
kind of explicit construction question
and there are two kinds of explicit
constructions that you can think about
weekly explicit and strongly explicit
let me talk about this here so I have an
algorithm which Prime tries by some
function parameter s which is given an
in whatever way you want and it's tries
to output the truth table of some
function of n tables which has large
circuit size bigger than this s so think
of as is something like super polynomial
or even exponential unity so it's easy
to construct something like that by
sampling things at random so you can get
an algorithm here to be probabilistic
algorithm it's just a stupid algorithm
which samples a random string and
outputs it and by Shannon's counting
argument that will work with high
probability because most functions are
hard what is much less trivial and with
in fact is not known is how to make this
more constructive so you want a
construction of this truth table that
will run in time polynomial in the size
of this combinatorial object the size of
this function and as I'll mention also
in his talk the existence of such an
algorithm which computes a truth table
of heart function and time polynomial in
the size of the truth table is
essentially the equivalent that is
equivalent to X not being in size s
simply if you want the language here
will be defined by this truth tables the
bios functions and give an input X you
just first compute the truth table of
the function then evaluate it at input X
takes exponential time now there's a
nice notion of so we don't we don't like
randomized construction here because
it's kind of trivial not very
interesting you can still use randomized
construction which look like should like
deterministic ones and this is a nice
framework of so-called pseudo
deterministic algorithms introduced by
God and goldwasser few years ago which
basically means that you have an
algorithm which uses randomness but if
you look at the output of the route and
you won't notice that because the
algorithm outputs always the same thing
no matter what randomness it uses this
means that you fix some truth table even
though use randomness so in more
classical terms the existence of such
pseudo deterministic algorithm with the
same running time as here would imply
that you have a heart function
computable in bpx bounded probabilistic
exponential time so these are weakly
explicit constructions and sometimes
people talk about X lower bounce against
explicit boolean functions and they
don't talk about functions computable
exponential time but something like an
empty in fact it's very natural to talk
about those in the context of strongly
expressed constructions like that so
here you can imagine that your algorithm
is going to be given not parameter and
but parameter X the position of the
object position in the truth table and
we'll compute just the value of function
f at that position so it's very similar
to when say we want to construct say
expanded graphs there are two notions of
explicitness you can use you can either
output the whole graph in time
polynomial in the size of the graph or
you want to be strongly explicit and
given a vertex in the graph and non
vertex in the graph you want to tell if
they're connected by nature or not
so that's exactly what's happening here
in a strongly explicit definition of
construction algorithm and you can talk
about this algorithm being polynomial
time which would translate that you have
P naught in size s okay so obviously S
can't be super polynomial in this case
or you can talk about your algorithm a
to be in non-domestic polynomial time
what it means is that for x on which the
function f is supposed to be 1 an
algorithm can you guess the witness and
certify the witness and on zeros of the
function f it cannot do its batches so
this gives you the strongly cliff
construction kind of correspond to the
notion of lower bounce against function
in NP and this is usually considered to
be explicit lower bounds
what we meant see it had youngnam AAS
from choosing different functions at
different axes so by the definition here
the function is supposed to be fixed
yes so it may not be cleared the way I
stated it here informally but the
function f is fixed and the algorithm is
supposed to reply consistently with
respect to that fixed function okay so n
is deterministic then it's always the
same function that the algorithm talks
about it's like when you want to
construct a graph you ask about the
neighborhood of this vertex the next
graph it's always about the same graph
it's not interesting to answer questions
about different graphs same thing here
the algorithm defines a function
identifies a function yes both cases yes
in both cases so you specify function
and then you can compute it as a truth
table or X by a random access so to
speak
okay so why do we need or how can we use
that mcsp algorithm if we had it well
it's similar to other commercial
constructions where you say okay you
want to construct a key material object
for certain property imagine that this
property were checkable easily then we
can just randomly guess and then check
and certify that this is object is good
and this way we can get something nice
with the property what would we
guaranteed to have this property say the
same thing here's a simple observation
that if minimum circuit size problem
we're easily checkable then you can just
guess a string check that it's hard and
have zero error
algorithm for generating our strings
which would imply that you can get rid
of two-sided error in beat the
algorithms and make them GDP what is
less straightforward is that if you
assume that mean oh sorry size problem
is in bbp then in fact you can get a
pseudo deterministic construction and
that would imply that bpx is not in P
slash poly
so here you don't have control of which
function you are putting randomly
whereas here you fix a particular
function we don't know how to answer an
interesting open question if I assume
that M CSV is in polynomial time can you
get at a fully deterministic
construction of hard truth tables would
be super interesting
okay so Rahul talked about explicit
constructions and I want to just add a
couple of remarks comments about this so
recently I was thinking like why can't
we construct our functions and are there
any similarities between what was going
on in exodus chimerical mineral
constructions in the literature in the
past and there are some interesting
objects that people want to construct
random objects for example air crackling
codes say linear era cracking codes over
a binary alphabet and expanding graphs
that I already mentioned so they should
random in a sense that if you sample
something at random then with high
probability you'll get what you want and
then what you want for linear codes you
want a code which has large minimum
distance okay I'm not going to define
those things here so it's just
impairment parameter of interest to the
person constructing those objects for
expanding graphs you want to have high
expansion and if you look at the papers
which proved that those parameters are
actually and be complete to check or
point be complete check indicates of
expansion they said but one of the
motivation is that if these parameters
were easy to check then you could give
could have Gaston object check it was
good and you have a nice sale in your
attic writing code for instance
unfortunately those parameters were
shown to be NP complete as people
suspected and both of those cases
actually took a while to show that those
parameters are np-complete and before it
I think this was around like for over 20
years and I forget this was also around
for some time before people figured out
how to prove those
[Music]
and sorry yes and whatever it says yes I
want certification yeah once your error
yes yes potentially yes okay I'm gonna
talk like a simple case yeah you're
right
so what does it take away message for so
what's what's my comment here so despite
the fact that checking the property is
really really hard it's np-complete and
we don't believe it's in power no time
we do have pretty decent constructions
of good objects good codes and good
expanders okay so the fact that the
property is hard to check does not mean
that it's impossible to construct an
object with the given property so that's
that's good news and kind of the bad
news so it depends how you look at it is
that well if you actually want to prove
and be completeness for the properties
you you care about like minimum distance
and expansion if you look at the proofs
of NP hardness for those properties in
fact they you'd rely on explicit
constructions of good objects it's like
similar to if you want to prove that
mcsp is hard then you kind of need to
have short get lower bounds before you
can finish the proof is good
constructions of hard functions before
you can complete and becomes it is proof
that's something that Rahul mentioning
is as well yes you can define related
property which guarantees the property
one and diversity
now understand but the point is that
there are some types of codes for which
we can compute the minimum distance yes
and that's what you need so it's like
there are some constructions of good
objects that already known and you can
use this construction to prevent the
hardness but also you have good
constructions right yeah so so what I'm
trying to say here that it should not be
an obstacle yeah and you're right like
for expander graphs the fact that you
can go to eigenvalues and those are
things are are very well understood
helps us to construct object with those
properties and for minimum distance we
have polynomial based construction say
of codes which we know how to analyze
really well but we don't have anything
like that for mcsp and moreover if you
look at the proofs another point I
wanted to make if you look at the and NP
hardness proofs for this problems it was
very important they have very good
handle on the parameters in question so
it's not enough to know them
approximately it it you need to know
them very well like to within basically
precisely in the case of minimum
distance for instance and it's related
to what Rahul was talking about like we
have DNF mcsp and the hardness result
because we really understand what gnf
looks like for a c0 we would need to it
looks like intuitively we would need to
know the circuit complexity of function
in h0 basically to within a constant
factor in front size and we don't have
anything like that
so it's a challenge for models where we
do have a very tight lower bounds with a
motivating factor try to prove NP
completeness on can be hardness for mcsp
for those models this question that I'll
be asked to do the expansion so there's
some natural boost expansion using a
second eigenvalue and for Eddie for
linear and reticles also natural foods
yeah I'm not sure if you have natural
post rolling your codes I'm not sure for
some families yes but not in general
so that was just an aside which took
some time you know by the way and it
takes a while so I've already mentioned
this results that if you look at like
naive attempts to reduce SATA mcsp
then you can show that yes you need some
kind of lower bounds and if you weaken
the requirement on your reduction then
you still have some kind of lower bounds
that you need to prove and if you wake
in the reduction way a lot then you can
prove that those reductions will not
work okay but still it leaves you quite
a bit of room first of all maybe even
this would work if you have strong
circuit lower bounds and secondly maybe
can relax your reduction to be probably
polynomial time and chewing and then
maybe everything
yeah and since I already talked about
that let me repeat this what what is a
natural property it's basically a
version of mcsp which can be thought of
as an average case version of mcsp and
more precisely given a truth table and
you have parameter s and you want to say
easy when the circuit complexity of the
function is less than s and if it's
bigger then you're not required to say
no but for at least half of the heart
functions you better say no okay so it's
like a one-sided average case problem
you always correct on the easy ones and
on hard once you correct on average most
of the time and that's basically
equivalent to the definition of a
natural property but as a whole
mentioned it's probably better to think
about natural property in this terms as
an average case problem and it's nice
it's interesting question to ask and we
can say something about that whether
having a good algorithm for the average
case mcsp allows you to get a good
algorithm for the worst case mcsp maybe
some version of worst case time CSP and
indeed it's possible and it follows from
this work on learning from natural
properties that are whole mention joined
with Marco Russell and Antonina and it
was also observed by Ritchie in his
paper this year that if you have an
algorithm for an average case mcsp then
you can solve some gap version of mcsp
in the worst case and let me just say
what the gap version is so it's
parameterize by easy and hard and you
require to say yes easy on functions
which are actually easy less than this
threshold and you're supposed to say
hard if the functions are hard bigger
than that threshold so you separate
easier from heart and you don't care
what happens in between so it's a
promise problem but you need to be worst
case correct on easy and hard ones
so so this direction is the interesting
one it says that from average case you
can get the worst case the opposite
direction is kind of straightforward if
you modify the parameters obviously if
you can solve the worst case you can
solve the average case problem so this
gives you some kind of interesting
equivalence between average case and
worst case problems variants of mcsp and
Sri Chi in his favor has much more on
this to say about connections to
Russell's fire whirls and stuff like
that
so just very briefly let me say how the
mcsp is helpful to get non-trivial
algorithms basic observation so if goes
let me define some notion which is a
very interesting notion so you have a
pseudo-random function generator or
candidates random function generator
what it is is that it's some function
which Maps a seed a random seed to a
long string and I think of this long
string as a truth table of a function so
it's a function generator it outputs a
function and we call such a function
generator local for some parameter s if
the complexity the circuit complexity of
this output is less than s in other
words whatever the generator spits out
for every fixed Z have small circuit
complexity less than s now if that's the
case then if you have an algorithm which
decides where the functions are easy and
hard versus hard then obviously you can
figure out if the string that comes at
you has small circuit complexity or it's
a random string which would have very
large circuit complexity so your mcsp
algorithm will be able to distinguish
between such easy functions coming from
the generator and through the random
strings which means that you would be
able to break the pseudo-random function
generator ok so if you LM CSP the
conclusion is that you can break every
local function generator now where do
you get this local generators from
that's proven rules in their paper
considered the gold radical Vasser
makalah construction of the random
function generator using cryptography
and they said well since this
construction gives you local function
generator if M CSP or if natural
property exists then we can break this
generator which means we can break or
invert any one wave function so that was
their choice of the local generator
in the learning paper we used a
different generator which happens to be
local as well and actually has been used
before for that property in the context
of proof complexity but a number of
people all hope to mention that in a
minute
and you start with NW nice and big
different generators and think of it as
a pseudo random function generator and
also argue that it's local if it's based
on an easy function rather than a hard
function which is the context where it's
usually used and then if your MCS pzz or
international property exists then you
can break this generator and you do the
reconstruction and you construct a small
circuit for the function a foundation
chain or what's that use so the
framework is exactly the same use
locality and in fact that mcsp
distinguishes local from random and if
you get different conclusions
okay so Rahul said that mcsp and SATA
kind of like jewels of each other one is
like white box complexity you're given a
circuit and you want to know if the
truth table computed by the circuit is
all zero or not it's like a white box to
give it a circuit and see it feels like
a black box given this whole truth table
you want to know if there's a small
circuit for it so it's quite surprising
that there should be any connection
between the two given on white versus
black box distinction that I just
mentioned intuitive distinction and we
have the result which says that well if
you can remove this distinction then the
two are actually equivalent and remove
this distinction you just assume the
existence of so-called
indistinguishability or for skaters and
the definition is given here roughly
speaking it's a randomized procedure
that preserves the functionality of a
circuit and make sure that two circuits
which are equivalent induce
indistinguishable distribution under
this transformation so if you compute
the same thing then you can create
distributions which occasionally
indistinguishable now intuitively that
takes a circuit and obfuscates it so it
kind of blurs the distinction between
white box and black box and so with that
in mind and shouldn't shouldn't be very
surprising that if you have this kind of
thing then the white box and black box
complexity suddenly become related I
will not give the proof of this it's not
very difficult
we'll be interesting to show something
like this without this assumption you
know open problems later
I'm almost done
so most known proofs of lower bounds for
weak circuit models are constructed and
that was observed by rasnov in his paper
from 1995 where he used the framework of
bounded arithmetic to show that you can
formalize all of these proofs including
hostel switching lemma for AC zero for
parity in relatively weak model of
so-called polynomial time reasoning we
won one second order theory not very
important just intuitively response to
some kind of polynomial time reasoning
what is interesting about this is that
this proof system or this the kind of
uniform proof system bad arithmetic is
like uniform version of your normal
proof system pro complexity systems what
is interesting about this if you can
form formalize very simple Shannon's
counting argument in something like V 1
1 which is the same system where we claw
bounds live then you get that X to the N
P is not in P slash poly and the reason
is same basses witnessing fear it's very
straightforward the point is that this
proof system is so constructive that
whenever it talks about the existence of
an object it has to be able to construct
it in polynomial time that's why it's
polynomial time system of reasoning
ok so even argue the existence of a
heart function already gives you some
handle on what the heart function is in
particularly can compute it in X to the
N P which we've done out
because this statement here is exist for
all statement so you need to go to
actually we want to and then the
witnessing theorem is not polynomial
time but polynomial with NP Oracle so
witnessing theorem says that if you have
a statement which says there exists some
object and there's some nice formula
certifying this object is good and if
you can prove in your proof system the
exist n shil statement like that then
from the proof you can extract a
polynomial time computation only no time
to a machine which will build such an
object so that's right the statement
itself it says that there is a function
such that for all small circuits there's
an input where they differ
so it's exist for all statement if it
there was no for all there then you'll
get palm on your time here so in
particular if mcsp we're in polynomial
time and moreover can be formalized in
v11 and you get X Martin / Paul away
from this degrees things I wonder if
that would be maybe already know ma yeah
so yes we we have a discussion with Sam
about this so yeah you can use you can
ask where can I prove this statements
and go to that theory and see see what
you're witnessing here would give you
and unfortunately it doesn't give you
anything that you don't know yes I need
to do something
so yeah so let me let me get to the next
slide so how is it related to a proof
complexity and heart at all just for
extended Fraga and the I think this is
program by most as borough of and I
think M tragic is also very much
interested in this of coming up with
autologous that would require
superpolynomial proof size for a very
strong proof system like extended Fraga
okay most people I think are one to some
kind of natural properties of natural
tautologies Rosberg says let's do this
so the ecology says that so you have a
truth tables of function f m and some
parameter s think of s is like
exponential and that the formula says
that the function does not have a small
circuit so the formula has variables
which kind of encode this circuit and it
says that for all circuits of small size
the circuit is wrong it disagree
disagree with my truth table in some
position okay so this formulas of size
polynomial in 2 to the N
and the question is whether you can
prove in extended Freyja such a
tautology in size polynomial in the size
of the formula I think as more
conjectures that that's not the case or
at least he thinks that that's very
interesting question to explore and he
make some progress toward that goal and
the best current result in this
direction is his result from 2015 where
he shows that if you go to rest absalom
again so some rasa version of resolution
where instead of usual disjunction you
have these junctions of ends of small
bottom fan and then such a proof system
cannot prove the state ologies in size
less than exponential this implies that
such a proof system cannot prove that
Sat is not in P slash poly so proof sets
at the vamp you slash pool if it's true
cannot be formalized in this proof
system another interesting thing I'm
almost done is that this approach to
prove lower bounds for such technologies
also goes we to the random generator
where you adapt to gram generators to
talk about generators secure against
proof systems and this goes back to work
by Alec knowledge bands as soon as bro
and avi and also krycek from like 2004
but in fact for every year exactly
exactly this is for any f whatsoever
so if FN is easier then of course the
calpro is hard but if a fan is any hard
function your proof will probably
require super power on those sites at
least that's the conjecture
it's interesting
0 of n squared for the same thing that
res log n isn't so bad
so I'm talking a little bit about just
gave you like a very impressionistic
sort of overview of this subject hoping
that what basement are all set to pick
your curiosity even further and say that
are very interesting unexpected
sometimes connections with the center
character beam mcsp and there will be
probably more connections discovered
hopefully during this semester
assignments I just want to highlight two
open problems one the one at Rahul also
highlighted an air calendar yesterday as
well can you prove circuit lower bounce
against mcsp for a c0 with more two
gates it seems like this should be
within our reach another one is kind of
related to trying to prove NP hardness
for mcsp but I state this thing in a
different form I say suppose M CSP is
easy and you have an algorithm for it
can you use possibly this algorithm to
solve Sat okay so it's different from
reducing satrap CSP yes it may be an
easier task and the result that uses in
distinguishability for skaters that I
mentioned is kind of that form it's not
a reduction from mcsp to sad or from
sometimes ESP it's assuming that mcsp is
easy to get an algorithm for sad it's
not a chiral induction know it's like in
circuit complex or in complexity if you
assume that that is easier if that is
easier than polynomial time higher the
collapses first of that flavor you need
to have an algorithm for that to come up
the polynomial time hardly need to have
an algorithm mm to speed to get longer
the force at
you would be applying the algorithm for
mcsp to a circuit coding the algorithm
for MCS be exactly exactly that's the
idea I don't know how to do it yeah
[Applause]
anybody who wants to ask questions so I
mean easy we've already very interesting
is where you have problem when two
people are completely specified and
they're to show that that problem is in
between by Saturday and that's connected
to learning because that's essentially
showing the red roses for example
absolutely yes
yeah so you allow to reduce this
statement to anything that you can
actually prove and I hope keeping it
non-trivial yes
the Mustang
[Applause]